in the last video we took essentially
the the length of y equals x squared
not the length but we went from zero to
one on the x axis
and you can kind of view it as this area
and we rotate it around the y-axis to
get this figure here and we figured out
the volume and i think our answer if i
remember it was like pi over 2. and we
use what we what i called and what
everyone calls the shell method i want
to show you that you could actually use
the disk method here but then we'll just
have to switch the y's and x instead of
writing this
you know
write the function as a function of x
we'll just take the inverse of it and
write it as a function of y so this
curve y equals x squared what it can
also be written as we can just take the
square root of both sides as x
is equal to the square root of y right
just take the square root of both sides
and now we can use this information to
do the disk method but
everywhere where we had an x in the past
we'll now have a y so let's let's think
about how we would do it so it's once
again it's this area
so and this will take and then really
the hardest thing about all of these
problems is just the visualization and i
think that's why they do it just to make
sure that you know how to visualize
things and maybe understand the calculus
it's more visualization than calculus
really
so we're still dealing with
you know if we take a cross section if
we were to just cut this figure
it would deal with
this area would be the cross section
right
so and we're still rotating around the
y-axis just like we did in the last
video we're still rotating around the
y-axis we get this figure so how would
we deal with disks well a disk would
look like this
say at some point let me pick a another
color
so at some point
we'd have a disk like that
that would be the
the top of the disk and it would have
some
depth
right like we did
before
and its height or the radius of that
disc
would be equal to x
right
it's equal to x and i know you're
thinking it looks like the shell method
but what is x equal to it's equal to the
square root of y
it equals the square root of y and what
would be the width of that disk
well now we're making everything as a
function of y so the width would be just
a very small distance d y the
differential y
and of course the um
all right and so that's that's
essentially all we need to know so the
volume of that disk would be the radius
squared times pi times d y
so let's
hopefully that that makes a little bit
of sense but there's another
hitch on this problem this is actually
similar to what we did two videos ago
because when you view it in the y-axis
from this y you can kind of say frame of
reference what we're going to do is
we're going to take the volume we can
take the volume of
of x is equal to 1
right so what would be the volume of x
is equal to 1 rotated around the x axis
it would just be it would be just the
entire cylinder
right so we're going to take
i want it's really important to
visualize this right what we're doing
so we're going to figure out this volume
volume of x is equal to 1.
let me draw the axis just so you know
what we're doing
so this would be the
y-axis
that would be the x-axis as best as i
could draw
and so we could do is originally we can
figure out the volume of the entire
cylinder right this is x is equal to one
x is equal to one
from what y points from the point well
what is this this is y equals 1
this is sorry y equals 1
to 0. so we would figure out this volume
from y equals 1 to 0.
and how would we do that
what would be the integral
and remember everything is in y now so
it might seem a little confusing
and so what is for each of these disks
right this is going to be made up of a
bunch of disks let me draw one of them
so let me draw the top one
the top
disc
and it has a width
and it's not going to be this entire
cylinder its width is d y its width is
just going to be this
d y very small sliver
d y and its radius is x or
or you could say
f of y
right
so what would be
the volume of that disc would be the
surface area of the top so it would be f
of y squared remember we're dealing
everything with y f of y squared
times pi that gives the area of the top
put the pi outside of the integral
times d y
d y and we said y is going from zero to
one
y is going from zero to one so that's
the enti that entire cylinder and what
we'll want to do is subtract out
essentially cut out the volume of the
inner bowl
so minus and so how would we figure out
the interval well that that's where we
will deal with the
x is equal to the square root of y
function
right because here what's each disk once
again it's f of y so let's i wrote this
generally this is f of y of the outside
outside
and i'm going to do now do it for the
inside i'm going to cut out the inside
volume and since i kept the general i
could do it we're still going from zero
to one from y equals zero to y equals 1
these remember we're dealing with y now
and now we'll take f of the inside
inside f of y
squared
d of y right and you can imagine in this
case the inside function we're going to
take the volume and here that original
disc i drew is actually one of the discs
for the inside function
where the height of that disc is d y
that should be d y
the radius of the disc is f of y and of
course the area of the top of the disk
is pi times the radius squared
now how do we apply it to this
particular situation well what is the
outside function f of y
x is equal to f of y we're just
switching the variables we said that x
is equal to one this is just a big
cylinder right so f of i is equal to one
in this function so we get pi
and we switch colors
times from zero to one
one squared
d y
minus pi
and we're still going from
zero to one
remember that's the y boundaries
and now what's f of y well here f of y
is square root of y
square root of y
squared
d y
right
and so this equals let's take the pi out
so this equals i'll write it up here
so
pi times
well one squared is one what's the
anti-derivative of one what
function's derivative is one well it's x
right
x that's the anti-derivative there and
we can kind of merge these we took the
pi out this y square root of y squared
this is just y
right oh sorry the antiderivative of 1.
see even i get quite confused here we're
taking this with respect to y right
so the antiderivative 1 now is y
right we're summing up a bunch of y's
right
i'm sorry i find this even a little
perplexing when i start switching x and
y's
but then
let's say the second function
remember we can merge these because it's
the same boundaries and they're both
with respect to y
square root of y squared is y what's the
antiderivative of
y the function y or y d y plus y squared
over 2
minus y
squared
over 2
right and we're going to evaluate that
at one and zero
and so what does that get us so we get
pi
so we get one minus one half
one minus one half
minus zero minus zero minus zero plus
zero over two
whatever these are zero one minus one
half that's one half
one half and then times pi is equal to
pi over two which is the exact same
result and i was worried because
you know you never know when you might
make a careless mistake as i often do
but we got the exact same result as i
got in the previous video when we used
the shell method and so the hardest
thing here is just remembering that
you're doing everything in terms of y
instead of the disks when we do that
when we did the disk method
traditionally the disks were vertical
disks now they're horizontal disks but
it's the exact same thing and you just
have to get your your your brain around
the idea that we're dealing with the y's
the boundaries on the integrals are now
y values we're taking the the width
of
the disks are now or the height of the
disks are d y and the radius is now the
function of y
hopefully i didn't confuse you too much
i made you know
my own brain malfunctioned a bit when i
took the anti-derivative one d y as it
should have been y but uh i will see you
in the next video where we will do even
more complicated problems where i'm sure
i'll make even more mistakes see you
soon